1086 in England has a new king and a new
royal family this new king was william
better known as William the Conqueror
and he was now indisputably in charge
the next year he died which caused
problems mostly for William due to the
whole being dead thing but also because
of the succession Norman inheritance law
was complicated but essentially the
father would give to the eldest son what
he himself had inherited and whatever he
had gained in life he could distribute
however he saw fit
William's eldest son was Robert who
under this law gained Normandy William
second eldest son was also called
William and he inherited England
becoming William the second but he's
better known as William Rufus Henry
Williams third son just got a wad of
cash and no land so being king is
objectively better than being a Duke and
so unsurprisingly Robert was none too
happy with his younger brother now being
his superior so at first both Robert and
William agreed to be each other's heirs
but this agreement broke down in 1088
this was when Robert with the help of
his barons attempted to overthrow
William so that he could be king the
Norman barons were faced with the issue
of owning lands in both Normandy and
England
this meant that if the brothers came to
blows the nobles would certainly have
had their lands confiscated in one place
or the other the barons wanted England
and Normandy to be United politically so
that it was easier for them to
concentrate on the external threats to
their holdings which at this point with
the King of France and the Duke of Anjou
the disagreement between the brothers is
known as the baronial rebellion of 1088
due to the number of nobles that picked
Robert over William it's included
widespread raiding across southern
England but the King eventually won out
by coercing some laws to rejoin him and
by capturing the leader of the revolt
Otto who was banished thereafter
during this rebellion against him
William Rufus had to deal with an
invasion from the Scottish King Malcolm
the 3rd William was busy fighting in
Normandy and so had to return to England
but Malcolm quickly signed a treaty
before any real retaliation could happen
the relationship between England and
Scotland during this period was
complicated and can essentially be
summed up as an uneasy stalemate
Scotland lacked the manpower to conquer
England and Scotland terrain made it too
expensive for an English army to hold
and thus the stalemate was continued
William a malcolm ended up coming to
blows again in 1091 when Malcolm invaded
England but was quickly stopped and
after this the kingdoms entered a period
of prolonged peace and mutual love or
perhaps not since in 1093 the Scottish
ravaged the lands of Northumbria the
Earl of Northumbria presumably annoyed
at his lands being destroyed ambushed
King Malcolm later the same year here at
a place called Ulm wick the ambushed or
King Malcolm and his son and heir Edward
killed thus ending the war
plunging Scotland into a dynastic crisis
Williams issues with his brother were
ended in 1095 not by a military victory
but by a stroke of luck when pope urban
ii began to preach for a crusade to
retake the holy city of jerusalem
Joop Robert now had an easy way out
which could potentially win him his own
lands as well as some glory
Robert thus leased Normandy to William
in order to finance his part in the
First Crusade this fortunate timing by
the church ended one of Williams
disputes but another was still raging
that of his relationship with the church
and specifically Anselm the Archbishop
of Canterbury and some believed that the
church did not answer to the king but to
God through the Pope this belief that
church men owed no allegiance to any
secular power did not sit well with
William boeuf argued for many years and
in 1097 Anselm was exiled and ended up
in Rome the next three years of Williams
reign were fairly secure and his power
remained unchallenged in 1100 Robert was
on his way back from the Crusades having
won glory and also a wealthy wife on the
way back and it seemed that conflict
between Robert and William was looming
in the same year William went hunting
with his younger brother Henry during
which he was killed in an era related
accident which in no way shape or form
looked suspicious before Williams body
was cold Henry had seized Winchester
which held the royal treasury and was
soon after coronated as King Henry the
first Henry had to move quickly to
secure the loyalty of his Lords and
prevent his returning brother from
overthrowing him on the day of his
coronation Henry issued was his called
the charter of liberties in which he
essentially repealed the unpopular
levels of his brother such as a noble
heir having to pay to claim his
inheritance so this is a good place to
explain just how the politics of the
nobility work during the Norman period
the main thing to remember here is that
a law did not own his lands but instead
they were leased from the king and
return for their loyal service and
Payman these Lords could in turn leased
these lands to lesser Lords who would
leased them in turn to the peasants who
worked them the centrality of land to
English life is hard to overstate - the
aristocracy clergy in the monarchy it
was the source of income and authority
but to everyone else King and peasant
alike it provided everything necessary
for medieval life its most obvious
output was food and feeding the kingdom
required the vast majority of the labour
force to be committed to agriculture
even with this commitment the amount of
food produced was not much of a
subsistence agriculture thus made up the
vast majority of England's economy he
had little in the way of raw materials
to export and besides that the most
lucrative of Europe's trade at this time
was centered on the Mediterranean
importantly the fact that everyday life
relied so much in agriculture man that
when there were major crop failures and
were many amend the people simply
starved so back to politics Robert
having returned to Normandy gathered
some of his Nobles and soon after
arrived in England landing in Portsmouth
here many English Nobles including the
powerful Robert of bollène flocked to
Juke Roberts side preparing to overthrow
Henry there was no battle and instead
the brothers agreed that Henry would
remain King but had to pay his brother
an annual sum Henry there moved against
believed seizing his lands in England
and banishing him this was done under
the pretext of belives unauthorized
conquest of parts of Wales than the
booting of castles there the reason for
this is that not just anyone was allowed
to build castles since a rebellious
noble could hold up him one and sieges
were long and expensive soon after this
Juke Robert allied with the exiled Billy
man Henry saw this as a betrayal in an
11:05 he invaded Normandy in 1106 Henry
met his brother at the Battle of
Tannenberg which saw Duke Robert
captured after which he would spend the
last 28 years of his life in captivity
Henry's reign was not a military like
his brother he had some trouble with the
church and some the exiled Archbishop of
Canterbury had returned to England in
1100 and had importantly supported
Henry's claim over his older brothers
this did not mean that the two were good
friends or anything since having spent a
couple of years in Rome and some had
become acquainted with the official
church policy on the appointment of
Bishops the position of the Pope was
that only he could appoint bishop since
Kings were simply laypeople concerned
with lesser earthly things and that the
Pope's were concerned with greater
heavenly issues unsurprisingly this did
not please Henry since appointing people
to important church positions was an
important way of making allies there was
some bickering between the two and
despite the king officially agreeing to
the demands his say-so was still very
important in deciding who would be
appointed he was only a technical
concession but importantly Henry had
agreed that he was a member of the laity
and that the Pope was above him in
authority so back to politics in Henry
having imprisoned his brother was now
also the duke of normandy meaning that
the main threats to his power were
external the two major threats were
lured the sick the King of France and
folk the fifth the Duke of Anjou the
former Duke Robert had a son William who
felt the normandy was rightfully his and
he sought the help of the other laws to
retake his birthright in 1118 with the
help of the Count of Flanders he led a
rebellion in Normandy which saw most of
the Duchy full but it dissipated quickly
after the Count of Flanders was injured
in the siege in the next year Louis the
six of France invaded but Henry led an
army against him and the French were
defeated at the Battle of Bream you'll
to finance this war immense taxes were
raised including the continuation of the
day in gold established under the
previous anglo-saxon monarchs henry was
notable for being
with the kingdom's finances the
evaluation of which was done with the
chequered piece of cloth called the
Exchequer by the way this is why the
modern minister in charge of the economy
is called the Chancellor of the
Exchequer Henry had just managed to
avoid catastrophe in losing Normandy but
his reign was made much more complicated
when his son William drowned in the
English Channel after his ship sank this
left Henry with no legitimate male heirs
only a daughter Matilda
in 1125 Matilda was left widowed after a
husband the Holy Roman Emperor died and
returned to England where King Henry
appointed her as his heir Matilda is
often referred to his Empress during
this period but after her husband died
she no longer held the title Henry
married her to the son of count folke
Evangel man called Geoffrey Plantagenet
Henry soon after fell out with Geoffrey
Matilda which meant that upon Henry's
death in 1135 a succession crisis would
break out so there was two potential
heirs for the English throne
the first was of course Geoffrey who at
the time of Henry's death was in Anjou
the other was Henry's nephew Stephen the
count of bolon given Henry's arguments
with Geoffrey Matilda the English Nobles
weren't too keen on them where Stephen
was very popular
fortunately for Stephen he was much
closer to England than his rivals
meaning he could act first which he did
he soon after arrived in London and
secured the support of the major Lords
and on December the 22nd he was crowned
King of England am a Duke of Normandy
major problems didn't begin for Steven
until 1138 when Robert the Earl of
Gloucester revolted against him
declaring for Matilda to make matters
worse Geoffrey who was now the count of
Anjou since his father had left to
become King of Jerusalem invaded
Normandy at the same time in the North
King David the first of Scotland invaded
in annex Carlisle this period of English
history is often referred to as the
anarchy but in many respects it was more
routine war of succession there were
rebelling lords and Aerys which English
Authority was shattered but ultimately
was no more anarchic than any of the
Civil War previous to this during the
Anarchy Stephen made several errors the
first was allowing Matilda to slip
through his grasp after she landed to
arendelle here and met with Earl Robert
of Gloucester in Bristol in 1139 his
next mistake was at the Battle of
Lincoln an 1141 in which instead of
retreating when the battle was going
against him Stephen continued to fight
and ended up getting yourself captured
and imprisoned they should have been the
end of the Civil War and Stephens reign
but that would have required the other
side to not make mistakes also which
they did
Matilda rented London and swiftly
offended everyone there and was chased
out shortly before her planned
coronation soon after that Oh Robert was
captured and Matilda agree to swap
prisoners Robert for Stephen which meant
the civil war would continue Geoffrey
conquered Normandy in 1140 for
whereas in England no headway was made
in the Civil War until Oh Robert died in
1147 and Mathilde realizing it was over
left the year afterwards in 1150
Geoffrey mate here Matilda's son Henry
the Duke of Normandy in Geoffrey himself
died a year later meaning Henry also
became the count of Anjou as well in
1152 King Louis the seventh divorced his
wife Eleanor of Aquitaine who roughly 11
seconds later married Henry giving him
Aquitaine as well and control of all of
this territory in a daring act Henry
sail to England to negotiate the
succession Stephens heir had died so it
was agreed that Stephen would remain
king but Henry would succeed him thus
peace was finally secured in England
Henry wouldn't have to wait long since
Stephen would die in 1154 and Henry
would succeed him as Henry the second
the first of the Plantagenet dynasty and
the man who ruled over all of this land
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching there are some
book recommendations in the description
if you'd like to know more
you